sin comida y con unas infraestructuras
devastadas el hambre aumenta las
tensiones en haití las zonas rurales la
ayuda humanitaria internacional llega a
cuentagotas tras el terremoto que acabó
con la vida de más de 2.000 personas y
deja más de 12.000 heridos el
nerviosismo entre la desesperada
población comienza a ser patente ante la
escasez de alimentos para gateway no
tengo trabajo no tengo agua no tengo
comida mi casa quedó destruida no hay
nada en youtube muchos habitantes
denunciaron que grupos pandilleros están
robando a la población los víveres
procedentes de las donaciones
internacionales en esta comuna cercana a
los cayos donde la población sobrevive
en improvisados campamentos la logística
de entrega de insumos se descontroló no
la presencia de efectivos policiales con
chalecos antibalas y casco logró calmar
los ánimos las condiciones para la
distribución están siendo un desafío
para las organizaciones que argumentan
son insuficientes
shakiro
daremos a cada familia 50 kilogramos de
alimentos que es el equivalente para una
familia de 5 personas debería durar un
mes es una ayuda muy básica diría que
insuficiente
personas tienen enormes necesidades
en medio del colapso hospitalario y de
infraestructura la única planta de
oxígeno medicinal del sur del país quedó
gravemente dañada por el sismo
hay una gran necesidad de oxígeno en
este momento todos los hospitales
nuestros clientes desde el coronavirus
hay mucha demanda la demanda de los
últimos dos meses aumentó más del 200
por ciento y ahora mismo no podemos
producir ni vender oxígeno
a más de medio millón de personas
necesita ayuda humanitaria urgente en
haití seis días después del terremoto
miles siguen al intemperie y el difícil
acceso por el colapso de las
infraestructuras está complicando las
tareas de los trabajadores humanitarios
para llegar a las víctimas